ancient statues are one of the most
awe-inspiring symbols of early western
civilization their masterfully crafted
details and smooth monochrome marble
surfaces give them an almost divine aura
the essence of an entire civilization
captured in stone a civilization that
would later go on to be the world's most
powerful and most developed caesar
augustus and his brilliant white form
represent a sort of divine stoicism
purity whiteness and a big load of
[ __ ] turns out the people of
antiquity really like their colors and
they especially liked painting statues
so how can we associate the ancient
world and their culture with this pure
whiteness which is in complete
opposition to reality also how does
barack obama relate to all this let's
find out after a quick word from today's
sponsor atlas vpn atlas vpn is a tool
that encrypts your data and hides your
virtual location thus protecting your
privacy and allowing you to bypass
region locks with atlas vpn you're going
to have access to all that content on
streaming platforms such as netflix that
has been previously logged away from you
all you need to do is open the
application pick a server from the list
and you're done atlas vpn also comes
bundled with a nifty breach scanner
feature open the menu inside the app
enter an email address and the app will
show you whether there have been any
leaks associated with that email address
and as an ended line of defense the app
also allows you to block unwanted
trackers from websites just flip the
switch and you're done right now atlas
vpn is running a huge discount on the
three-year plan this means you can
subscribe to their services for just one
dollar and 39 cents per month this and
the 30-day money-back guarantee of
course this offer won't last forever so
do check it out link in the description
atlas vpn runs both on desktop and on
mobile and of course it's compatible
with all major operating systems protect
your privacy and don't let region blocks
stop you take advantage of this insane
discount today thank you for checking
out atlas vpn ads like this help support
the show you will find my affiliate link
down in the description
modern society viewing ancient statues
as these pure white objects began as an
honest mistake really and this
originates from the renaissance era
where people started to appreciate
ancient cultures once more at this point
pretty much all ancient statues were
either buried underground or exposed to
the elements for hundreds of years which
caused all the paint to erode basically
and so people at the time just assumed
that this is how these statues were
intended to be now this wasn't a problem
per se what was a problem is people
trying to recreate ancient statues and
buildings based on this false idea for
example here's the popular building in
munich it's a neoclassical building
finished in 1862 and as you can see it
is all white or how about this building
which i assume doesn't need an
introduction or this one and this one is
the hungarian national museum all of
them neoclassical and all of them snow
white meanwhile ancient greeks
absolutely loved painting their
buildings but to the modern observers
all these painted statues and buildings
just look weird at exhibitions of
repainted statues visitors have
repeatedly found the colors tasteless
fabio barry an art historian at stamford
described the recolored augustus statue
as a crossdresser trying to hail a taxi
and boy i sure hope there isn't no
distinct segment of society that ties
its entire identity to this false
aesthetic right so when sarah e bond an
associate professor of history published
her essay entitled why we need to start
seeing the classical world in color she
of course started receiving a bunch of
hate mail from butthurt white
supremacists left they starter
snowflakes by the way so yeah my biggest
problem with this whole statue color
business is the racial ideology which is
built on top of it this fundamental
misunderstanding of ancient cultures
feeds into this modern myth of white
supremacy the sole purpose of which is
to belittle dehumanize and exclude
non-whites and turns out this collective
misunderstanding of the ancient world is
the perfect breeding ground for such
ideas the reason why you and i might
look at these statues and think they are
tacky or tasteless is because we have
been culturally conditioned to think
that way in contemporary western culture
whiteness came to be associated with
purity seriousness professionalism
cleanliness and most importantly order
and civilization you know it was us the
the whites who built all these nice
white buildings and sculpted all these
nice white statues you know all these
extra colors are reserved mostly for
these silly brown people who live
somewhere down south whom we sometimes
might visit as tourists mind you to
enjoy their silly brown people things
and then once we had our fun off we go
back to our nice white citadel of
progress and development right so this
is the level of the average facebook
boomer i would say but then comes the
white nationalist and says all of this
is because white people are genetically
superior and this might be a very
compelling intuitive argument if you are
below 14 or above 70 but only until the
realization that these far-right idols
are in fact false there is nothing
fundamentally civilized or refined about
the color white it's a complete cultural
fabrication which by the way the people
of antiquity would have disagreed with
putting out a pure white statue would
have meant that you are too poor to
afford paint and are now looking to
raise money being too white as a male
meant that you are a [ __ ] real men had
brown skin white skin was a thing for
women though but more on a financial
basis as in fair-skinned women being
affluent enough supposedly to not have
to work outside all day long the modern
racialized concept of whiteness just
didn't really exist back then but
through this misinterpretation of
classical cultures we get to pretend
that it did now i know what you're
thinking how does barack obama fit into
all this let me explain barack obama is
considered black he is not considered
white well you know duh obviously right
but hold on a second barack obama is
half white half black so how come he's
not considered both black and white at
the same time well that's because
whiteness is exclusionary its obsession
with purity produces this ever-shrinking
group of worthy individuals a huge air
code surround worthy but what these
identity evoropa types don't realize is
that this concept is doomed to fail
civilizations that turn exclusionary
will not stand the test of time as they
say the roman empire whose aesthetic
these people love so much could only
grow so great and powerful because it
included people it being an early white
civilization is just a flat out lie the
circle of citizenship the rough
equivalent of whiteness back in the day
constantly expanded the empire losing
its ability to include people was one of
the most important factors in its fall
if not the most important a great
contemporary example for this would of
course be the u.s republican party with
their southern strategy they went on a
path of exclusion instead of inclusion
but after years of presidential
victories the consequences are coming
back to haunt them when it comes to
presidential elections the republican
party has not won a single popular vote
since 1988 except for 2004 fresh after 9
11 and at the start of the iraqi war now
republicans can still theoretically eke
out some victories but through more and
more uninspiring means tell me what does
it say about your political movement
that you have to resort to electoral
[ __ ] to win against hillary [ __ ]
clinton what does it mean about your
racial ideology that you would either
need to deport all non-white people or
forbid race mixing otherwise it wouldn't
survive we have to let this idea go that
the ancient world was white both in
terms of people and statues so i say
let's paint them all these statues that
is all of them should have their
original colors restored let people
realize that their views of the ancient
world might have been false and in the
process take away a major propaganda
tool from the far right and if the
colorful statues upset you i'm sorry
historical facts don't care about your
feelings thank you for watching
paint them all don't forget to like and
subscribe and if you think this content
is worth your money then there is a
patreon link in the description and i'll
be seeing you next time